[Music]
hello everyone
uh we'll start our discussion uh or
we'll continue with our discussions of
problems in this lecture now as you can
see here
i have already drawn the diagram it is
again a simply supported beam
where the loading is in the form of a
point force acting vertically downward
at the mid mid-span of the beam so you
understand that the center length is l
and this p is acting this point force p
is acting
at a distance l by 2 from the left end
the cross section is also very familiar
to us the simplest
of cross sections the rectangular cross
section having width b
and height h however
the big difference that this problem has
is that
the material behavior is not linear
the material behavior here is given by
sigma is equal to some coefficient
k times epsilon to the power 1 by 3.
now you note that no subscripts are
given here
uh that is because we are still adhering
to the understanding that for this kind
of a problem
the dominant focus the the dominant
stress rather
will be still in the form of sigma
xx where we understand that x
is in this direction okay so maybe i can
specify that
more clearly that this still is our x
direction
and this is indeed sigma xx
now we could have a more general
non-linear
behavior representation of that
but at least for our current purposes of
illustrating a problem
uh where castigliano's theorem is used
we will take this kind of a
simple non-linear behavior and see what
is the implication of it
you will you will find out in the course
of this lecture
that we'll have to go through certain
involved
things now towards that end
uh first of all we note what are the
things that are similar
with our previous understanding first
you note
that all the things that are related to
the
statics aspect of this problem meaning
that how the reaction forces will be as
you can understand directly from
a visual inspection of this problem and
based on all your undergraduate
experiences
the reaction forces here will be p by 2
at this end
and p by 2 at this end both acting
vertically upward that does not change
certainly furthermore the connection
that the strain has with the geometry
which we have developed of which we
which you all know from our
undergraduate studies
on beams that also does not change
what will change however is every
everything or every aspect associated
uh with those formula which
does involve this kind of a connection
between sigma
and epsilon so first of all you note
that earlier we have we have talked
about
a simply supported beam problem where
the material behavior was very much
linear elastic
and there we had
we had used this this formula
which we had developed earlier that
that the deflection
okay so please note that for linear
or linear elastic behavior or linear
materials
or linear material behavior
d is equal to
like this where u mind you
is the strain energy and we have already
seen
that this strain energy
it can be represented for the case of a
beam
in this form m squared by twice e i
dx going the entire span of the beam
from length from 0 to l
and this can be further simplified to
[Music]
del m sorry about that
okay so we had been we have been using
this uh
this formula furthermore as a corollary
to the caustic lineus theorem
uh we had also noticed that we could
have a corresponding
formula for the slope uh where
we noted that theta is equal to del u
del m where m represents the bending
moment
okay the point here is that
this all these things is not going to be
valid
okay not valid
here because of
of non-linear material behavior this is
the
absolute fundamental
thing that we have to understand
so what can we use okay so towards that
end you first of all note
that what is the expression for this
m okay we can start off
with uh from scratch basically from the
understanding that the bending moment is
basically
uh a manifestation of
the the forces uh
that are induced or or connected with
the sigma xx
and we directly use the geometry that we
have for our problem here
uh so this bdy
it represents an element a thin strip
in elemental strip here and we
take the integration from over the
entire height of this cross section
okay this y here is the moment arm
all right so you all know this but let
us see
what is the implication of using
this expression of sigma
here so we if we use that
what we are going to obtain let me
quickly go through it
now what you see as i had already
mentioned
the connection that the strain has with
the geometry
that does not change even though
the stress strain relation has become
non-linear okay so the kinematics part
that is not changing so if the
kinematics part is not changing
what what we note that epsilon
that we understand like this
is still very much given by this formula
that epsilon is equal to y by r where
this capital r it represents the radius
of curvature
it represents the radius of curvature
many of you who have had a very strong
gate preparation
uh things like our formula like this
m r is equal to e i
those kinds of things would be very much
at your fingertips
and please note that the r that you have
over there in that formula it is that
same r
okay it is the radius of curvature but
uh as we'll see we have to specialize
this
or we have to generalize this to the to
the fact that this is the
local radius of curvature okay in any
case
uh for our present purposes we proceed
with the
application of this formula
uh for for for the students who may not
have
uh gone through a gate preparation
please note that
this uh this formula it basically
arises from uh the
fundamental uh well i should not say
fundamental but
the very elementary euler bernoulli beam
hypothesis
came so uh if you are not uh
if you don't recall it i suggest that
you go back to your undergraduate
textbook and you will find the
discussion
in the chapter on bending or maybe
even in the chapter on flexural stresses
or bending stresses
okay we have this one by three over here
like that and
[Music]
now see i can take this k out of this
integration i can also take this
r to the power 1 by 3 out of this
integration because you note that this
r could in general vary along the span
of the beam
that is along the x direction but here
we are
taking here we are carrying out this
integration over a particular cross
section
so at a particular cross section we are
at a certain
given distance x from the origin
okay so there is no the chance of r
varying over the
over the y which is uh which is what
this integration
is with respect to so we can take this
k out we can take this b out this
r to the power 1 by 3 out and what we
are left inside
is this integration minus h by 2 to h by
2
y so this 1 by 3 and this one together
it gives me a 4 by 3
and this is where you will note that
things
start to become a little bit weird but
also certainly very interesting
and you get to see the direct
implication of the non-linear behavior
okay so proceeding with the algebra
what we left in is
this y to the power of
seven by three divided by seven by three
uh
i mean the first time you do it uh
it all sounds a little bit uh i mean
quite offbeat
but not to worry
and please note that we have the
integration limits over here
h by 2 to minus h by 2 so that gives me
h by 2
1 by 3 minus of minus h by 2
7 by 3.
overall what this will give me so i'll
get a 2
twice of h by 2 to the power 7 by 3 over
here
and together that is going to give me
this 6 a b
and 7 remains as it is and there is this
h
by 2 to the power 7 by three
okay so basically uh this this gives me
a twice
that twice i have multiplied okay so uh
you see this n is this uh
this weird looking uh complicated
looking thing
up but overall you please note that
uh what is happening what is really
happening here
this 6 a constant this k
is another constant which is very much
part of the material behavior here
the b is also a a geometrical constant
for our problem because it is just the
width of this cross section
even though we have this horrible
looking 7 by 3 power over here but it is
ultimately
oh this entire term is just a constant
because this h
is also a geometrical constant in the
height of the cross section which is
which is very much known so what we have
obtained through this integration is
basically a connection between this
m the bending moment and
this r the radius of curvature
okay now please note that in in this
rough
i mean just as a side note i had
mentioned
that uh many of you who had uh
who have had a very strong gait
preparation you would know
you'd recall this formula this m r is
equal to
e i now for
our non-linear behavior this formula
is no longer valid rather what we are
obtaining
okay what we are obtaining is this kind
of an alternative formula okay so please
note
that this no longer works okay rather
we have the alternative version of that
for the for the particular case of the
non-linear behavior
given by this sigma is equal to k
epsilon to the power 1 by 3
where you note that so see here for the
linear behavior
you had basically m is equal to e i
divided by
r where this e was the material constant
i was the second moment of inertia for
the second moment of area
which included within it just the
geometrical parameters
and in the denominator you had this r
okay so m is equal to e
i by r that was for the linear behavior
now if you just try to make or draw an
analogy with that
you will see that here also in the
numerator
we have just like we had the e there we
have this k
here which is accounting for this
material behavior some kind of a
coefficient
in the material behavior this b times h
by 2 to the power 7 by 3
that is taking on the responsibility of
the second moment of area this please
note that i am not
saying that this is the second moment of
it is certainly not the second moment of
area for this cross section is exactly
what you have
what you know okay it is still 1 by 12 b
h to the power b h cube so
so that is that is not a problem that is
still very much there
but what i'm saying is that just like
you had the presence of the
i in that linear behavior formula so
also we have the presence of the
geometrical parameters
in this uh through these terms okay
and just like we have this r in the
denominator
over here so also we have this r to the
power one by three
okay and you note that this 1 by 3 has
this connection with this
okay so depending on the on the specific
kind of material behavior that
that will be dealing with will have
different different connections
between the m and the radius of
curvature
okay that is an important lesson to have
all right
so in order to make our steps easier
for uh for what for the subsequent steps
that will be carrying out
what we'll do is we'll make a direct
connection
not between m and to this weird looking
r to the power one by three
rather we'll make this thing simpler in
the next page
uh so i'll just i'll just repeat this
thing
let me just copy it
go to the next page
and note that
my m
is is this thing okay
now if i am uh
since i want to simplify the expressions
further along what i will do is
i will take this entire combination 6 by
7
kb times h by 2 to the power 7 by 3
and put it inside the single constant c
with the r to the power 1 by 3 remaining
outside
so what this is going to give me is
uh i can i can put a c dash over here so
that
finally what i can have is this m
q is equal to c by
r okay where you understand that this c
is basically is the cube of this c dash
okay so this is the thing that we are
going to use subsequently
now how do we proceed from here it is
just the expression of the m that we
have found out
let us not lose sight of the fact that
our interest here is to find out the
deflection
uh at the point of application of that
force p
okay now as i've mentioned earlier for
this
non-linear behavior we really have to
use the
complementary energy okay we have to we
cannot rely
on the strain energy so uh
so what we'll do is uh we will
we'll consider this uh so it may seem
like for apparently no
rhyme or reason i'm doing this but you
will get the hang of it in
in just a minute okay so do you d
d u dash so where this u dash is the
is the complementary energy and we're
taking the differential of that so
and i want to represent it in this
fashion
okay so this is very much uh reminiscent
of uh of the
things that we were doing as part of our
proof of
the castiglione's theorem on deflections
except that now we are writing the
differential here not in terms of the
applied force
rather in terms of the bending moment
okay
now we have already uh talked about the
corollary to the castiline's theorem and
we know that this particular thing
uh we are we are saying that that is the
slope
uh so so this is
like theta dm
okay now again we'll be appealing
to our geometrical understanding of the
problem
and note that suppose we have a part of
the beam
like this which has bent like this
and you think that this is some length l
okay so when i say length l i do not
mean
the the capital l which represents the
entire span of the beam
rather it is some length l okay over
which
the curvature is not changing and
subsequently will i will specialize this
l
to a differential element okay but let
us not complicate things
at one go uh step by step we'll proceed
so
the uh if the curvature of
of this uh this little portion
is so if this curvature is
r then you understand
that this theta will be given
by l by r
let me write that in yellow it will be
given by l by
r please note that i am only
and only appealing to the geometry here
okay
so you know that l is equal to r theta
so that's what i'm using here
okay now uh
instead of talking about this
differentials
uh perhaps we can
write that equal to sign also in yellow
everything is nice and consistent so
this u dash
can we not write it as
in this fashion okay so please note what
i have done here is that
i've carried out the the integrations on
both the sides
uh taking as a limit on the left hand
side
integration from 0 to u dash that's how
i get this u dash
and on the right hand side i'm carrying
out this integration from 0 to m
okay so what good does this do me
okay so all these these steps that i'm
doing right
right now it may seem a little bit
arbitrary
okay but you will see the benefit of
this
in in just a short while uh
for now what i'll do is uh
i will write this i'll take this l out
of the integration
okay that doesn't matter
it is like this
and what i will do is this entire
integration
that you note is some function
of the bending moment and it is exactly
that what i'm going to write this
so the u dash
it's like this now what is the benefit
of actually writing like this
benefit is that uh with this
understanding that if we have this kind
of a formula
for a length of the beam over which the
radius is not changing
then in order to account for the entire
length of the beam
what we can do is we can
just carry out an integration but now
considering that this
l is actually like a differential
element
okay so this could have been done in a
more formal fashion
but we are proceeding like
engineers okay so had we been in a
proper maths class
then things would have been done in a
slightly different fashion
but uh those to those who are more
mathematically inclined
i i apologize uh for this lack of
record and formalism okay but i hope uh
but but the things that we are doing
that is certainly not wrong
okay now uh
with this understanding uh what can we
do regarding the
deflection because you see what we have
basically managed to do through these
rather arbitrary steps is to write
an expression for the complementary
energy
as some function of the m over the
integrated over dental length
so this is the counterpart of what we
had written
earlier for the strain energy
as m square by twice
e i d x integrated from 0 to l
that is what we are trying to get at
okay so for the
for the case of the linear material for
a beam we had obtained this formula
but please note that because now we are
dealing
with the non-linear behavior we can no
longer deal with this
first of all we had noted that we can
not even
proceed by the root of the strain energy
we have to do with the complementary
energy
but you would still like to make the
connection with the bending moment so
that is exactly what we have managed to
do here we have
written on the left hand side the
complementary energy
but on the right hand side there is an
integration over some function of the
bending moment
just like we had earlier some function
of the bending moment here
okay so i'm just trying to draw an
analogy here
so now that we have this can we perhaps
hope
to find out the deflection okay by using
the castigliano's theorem let's try to
do that
so for deflection
will have d
del u dash del p so when i'm writing
this i'm directly
utilizing castigliano's theorem on
deflection
of where this u dash is definitely
the complementary energy now
uh in the previous step uh i had
obtained
this u dash in this fashion
okay it was that this f is a function of
m
uh over with respect to
x so this thing
can be written like this and then it can
be written like this
please note again okay at every step you
should try to draw an analogy with what
we had done
earlier so earlier
we had this u is equal to
m square by twice e i
d x integration from 0 to l and then
when we wanted to find out the
deflection what we did was del u del
p and then we found out that to be equal
to
0 to l m by e
i del m del p
dx okay so you see this del m del p
business is still very much present in
our current formula
but this m by e i that we had obtained
very simply
which and which you note is
is actually 1 by r because m r is equal
to e i
many of you know this so this thing
the counterpart of that for our
non-linear behavior is this del f del m
okay now let's see
uh what is this del f del m okay
so uh
so earlier in the in the previous page
we had already said that
so our fm
is basically just this integration 0 to
m this is oh sorry
right so
does this not give us
you think about this for a moment okay
so if we have this sort of an
integration
does this not imply this okay so
probably you can think of going from
this side to this side
that will probably clarify your
understanding
okay now if we have this then you see
that what we had obtained earlier okay
so that
we had this 1 by r del m del p
is it not the same as as what we have
now
okay but the root is is quite different
but it is extremely important not to
jump to conclusion and say that this
this thing and this thing is the same it
is certainly not
and why it is not the same thing
you see although this this del f del m
may be equal to 1 by r so indeed we can
write this
um d is equal to
1 by r del
m del p and that probably makes us very
happy that okay we have finally arrived
at a form which is very much looking
like the previous form
but you see this 1 by r the connection
with the
m that is not so simple okay
because we had earlier obtained that
mq
but we have earlier obtained
m cube is equal to c by
r okay if you look back at the previous
pages
uh you will you'll find that okay or if
you just uh
pause the video and maybe go back in a
few minutes you'll find that
uh all right so
uh so and also let us not forget that
this c
it is it is a constant which involves
within it uh
various coefficients uh like the k
the material behavior constant as well
as the dependence on the width of the
cross section
and the height of the cross section okay
so with this uh
with these pieces of information we can
go to the next page
and actually carry out this uh
integration
[Music]
so you see this this is 1 by r that we
have so
what we need is n cube by c so i am
replacing this 1 by r
by m cube by c that's what i would have
just done here
this one by the same cube by c so
that and
for the for the beam problem that we
have at our hand
because it is symmetric about x equal to
l by 2 we have already seen that
that symmetry can be exploited to
simplify the
the calculation of this integration so
what we have is
this integration from 0 to l by 2
because we understand that whatever is
the situation from 0 to l by 2
is exactly the same situation from l to
l by 2 moving in the opposite
direction so
like this
furthermore our uh expression for
m can be written down in terms of
the uh of the of the reaction forces so
uh this and that thing can be
simplified uh considerably so
if you if you just look back
the original diagram what i'm saying is
that
if you take a cut section like this so
maybe i just copy this thing
this will be better so what i'm doing is
i'm taking a cut section here
and
i'm considering the part of the beam
which is to the left of the cross
section
of this cut section
i am considering this reaction force
which is sorry about that
which is p by 2 and uh
i have the bending moment here
this is the shear force and this
uh expression of the bending moment this
m
uh if this this is in the in the
anticlockwise sense
and the moment contributed by this p by
2
about an axis passing through this end
will be equal to p by 2 times
x we write that
and since the sense of that will be in
the clockwise sense
will be minus so
we have m is equal to
e by 2 times x so if we substitute that
here and carry out
our entire calculations we're going to
find out the answer
okay so uh let me not uh
i mean invest any more time on this
i would suggest that
whatever we have done here uh
you please try to repeat this maybe with
a slightly different kind of material
behavior
because if you do that you will see uh
what are the things which we have done
as part of this problem
uh which do not change uh
so uh there will be certain things
like which will be just like an exact
replication
in every non-linear problem that you do
but there will be certain things
uh for example the connection between
the
m and the radius of curvature of the
specific
uh forms that you end up with
those will be different depending on the
kind of material behavior you choose
so if you do a slightly different kind
of problem uh
you will be able to see the things which
which do remain the same for different
non-linear problems and the things
which do actually change on nonlinear
problems okay and this will
and that will definitely help you to get
a clearer picture
uh in contrast to the things that we
have been discussing
uh compared to the linear behavior
so on that note i will end this video
thank you very much